now why is this so dicey well the first
thing I'm going to do is I'm going to
try and get it into the same shape that
I saw over here so see this half what
kind of part of the shape is it altering
is it horizontal or vertical it's
vertical right so I think really this
half this constant belongs with the wire
because that's the vertical thing right
so I'm gonna write this as 2 y cos
inverse 2x minus 1 okay now what's it I
see about this what I see students do
year after year after year is you've
been so well trained to say oh look see
that do you remember back from auxiliary
angle remember axillary angle way back
last year if that was like say PI on 6
you'd be like oh I shift by PI on 6 yeah
and students will look at this and say I
will shift horizontally one unit that's
what it looks like right one unit which
way by the way to the to the right yeah
because it's that weird opposite thing
except as you're about to see you do not
shift one unit to the right and this
approach will help us see why ok let's
look at this part firstly what's the
normal range of cos inverse we're not
signing us anymore we'll think it cos
inverse do you remember what the range
is it goes from 0 to PI I don't have Y
there though I've got two Y in there is
that ok so now to get the real range out
of this sorry I should have written off
a range to get the real range out of
this what shall i divide by that's easy
0 / - why / - why / - fine / - happy
times okay but now have a look at the
domain and how weird it is okay what's
the regular domain of cos inverse how
far you going negative 1 to 1
it's the same but what I've got between
negative 1 and 1 is this weird beast
okay now have a look at this
how do I get the domain out of this what
about what's the first thing you'd like
me to do I'll add one to everything
everything so that turns this into a
zero it turns this into 2x and it turns
this into two does that make sense but I
don't have the domain just yet do I
start to do one more step which is
divided by two so that gives me this yes
are you ready to draw it one of the nice
things about doing this first is you now
automatically know which part of the
graph you actually need to draw so I
don't need anything
oh sorry I don't need anything over here
in fact this whole thing is in the first
quadrant do you see the values okay it's
cos inverse is that the one that is
increasing or the one that's decreasing
it's decreasing we just established that
over here so I'm going to start from PI
on two
here we go I'm gonna start up here right
and then I'm gonna curve downwards until
I get to here okay so do you see what's
just happened this is from 0 to 1 and 0
to PI on to okay it's not that you just
move over one unit okay in fact if you
think about where the center of centre
of motion is if you're like where is
that where is the center it's at 1/2 at
halfway between why have you only moved
half a unit and not a whole unit over
because there's no there's no half in
here what's going on there actually is a
half in there we just haven't written it
in such a case to show that see visiting
here can you see how we could write it
to show that it really is 1/2 that's who
their right is really to outside of X
minus 1/2 that's the real shift that's
happened it started at 0 the center
information and it moved over half a
unit I guess the way you can think about
is this one has been split into two and
if this was a 3 to be split into 3 you'd
only move a third of unit or whatever it
might be okay so what I love about
making sure you get the range in the
domain right is that it's really hard to
screw this up and we're
in exam and I'm rushing right I will
often get this backwards or I'll do this
shift instead of that squeeze or
whatever I'll do it in the wrong order
but this is just algebra you're getting
much better at this right and then once
you have that you can't argue with it
you know exactly where it's going to go
okay so when you get into once and I
know some of you are making great
progress through it but others of you
are just started yet
when you encounter these questions like
this the question might not even ask for
domain and range but I'm gonna encourage
you to work that out first because it
really helps you with the graph